you
you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
New Horizons for protein degradation
immediate selective protein control
using the d tag system presented by dr.
Chris phenom naved Research Fellow Dana
Farber Cancer Institute laboratory of
Nathaniel gray and Christie jewel of
labret and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminars brought
to you by labyrinth and sponsored by
cell signaling technology for more
information on our sponsor please visit
cell signal calm now let's get started I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive and we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I'd like I'd now like to introduce our
presenter dr. banana Ben phenomena vet
is a postdoctoral research fellow in the
laboratory of dr. Nathaniel gray at the
Dana Farber Cancer Institute dr. new bet
received his PhD in cancer biology from
Northwestern University and a BA in
biology from the University of
Pennsylvania in his postdoctoral
research dr. the vets developed a
generalizable technology platform known
as the D tag system to rapidly degrade
any target protein of interest to read
more about dr. naved and the d tag
system please visit the biography tab at
the top of your screen
crashing abet you may now begin your
presentation
okay great well thank you very much for
the kind introduction and for the
invitation to present today in today's
webinar of webinar series so as was
mentioned I'm a postdoctoral fellow in
the laboratory of Nathaniel gray and the
work that I wanted to share with you
today I actually started under the joint
mentorship of Jay Brandner and Nathaniel
prior to Jays departure to lead Novartis
research broadly we're interested in
developing chemical tools and strategies
to not only inhibit target proteins of
interest but actually send them to the
proteasome for degradation and today I
wanted to highlight some of our ongoing
work in the development of a technology
platform that we call the D tag system
that allows us to degrade any target
protein of interest for many years now
we've been interested in this small
molecule known as the lid amide the Lin
amide is quite infamous in part because
back in the 1950s it was used as a
treatment for pregnant women to help
with their morning sickness subsequently
children that were born from pregnant
mothers that took the lid amide had very
catastrophic consequences this set led
to severe birth defects and limb
abnormalities that are shown in this
image here a major breakthrough came
back in 2010 when hashira Honda's lab
demonstrated that the cellular target of
thalidomide is actually this protein
known as Sarah bland or CR BN what the
Honda lab showed was that this image
could actually bind to Sarah bond which
is part which is an e3 ubiquitin ligase
that's part of the call for a complex
that's depicted here
subsequently bill Kaelyn slab Benny Bert
slab and Eric Fischer prior to his moved
to Dana Farber demonstrated that
lenalidomide and image derivative has
its antineoplastic activity by
modulating sarabande target recognition
so in this case when an image biases
sarah bond it also engages what we call
a neo substrate as a result this leads
to ternary complex formation and the
ubiquitination of this neo substrate and
subsequent proteasome well media
mediated degradation what these
investigators showed was in fact that
there are many neo substrates that are
engaged upon treatment with an image
initially they described it grows and
alias to very important cell
type-specific transcription factors that
are degraded in multiple myeloma in MDS
context this leads to the antineoplastic
activity of limit lenalidomide in this
context this was quite exciting to us
because in part we thought well perhaps
since the image buying - Sarah blonde we
could engage Sarah blonde and direct
this as to degrade a particular target
of interest that we wanted to selfs
degree this led to the hypothesis that
we could generate hetero bi-functional
small molecules were on one end they
were hooked up to solute amide engaging
Sarah blonde and on the other end hooked
up to another small molecule ligand or a
binder with high affinity that could
engage a target protein of interest as a
result we could direct the cells to
ubiquitin aid and then subsequently
degrade that particular target protein
of interest with this by functional
molecule I should note that this idea
has been around in a literature for
quite some time and highlighted here in
this old patent application indicating
that perhaps by functional molecules or
glue like molecules that could engage a
target protein and the ubiquitination
system might actually be able to
engineer such a response
so we thought that perhaps this strategy
of targeted protein degradation might
have many advantages compared to small
molecule inhibitors over the past
several years we and others have been
able to demonstrate in fact that some of
these hypotheses seem to be correct
we're particularly excited about
targeted protein degradation because
this allows an investigator to
selectively immediately and reversibly
control a specific target protein of
interest we and others have found that
compared to small molecule inhibitors
these degraders can have improved
selectivity and prolonged effects both
in vitro as well as in vivo in addition
these strategies allow one to deplete
the entire protein rather than targeting
one specific domain which is a
limitation of small molecule inhibitors
what I'll show throughout the
presentation as well is that we found
that degrading a target of interest
actually pairs very well with genetic
approaches these includes knockdown or
knockout experiments as well and finally
we are particularly excited about this
approach because it opens the door and
it gives us an opportunity to tackle
very difficult drug targets that have
been recalcitrant to small molecule
based approaches in the past so back in
2015 J radner's lab demonstrated that
they could develop hetero by functional
small molecule degraders of the bed
bromodomain family well gay adventure
and Dennis Buckley two very talented
postdoctoral fellows that were
previously in the Brandner lab
demonstrated was that they could take
jun cheese famous molecule jq1 the
target spirity 2 3 & 4 and conjugated to
thalidomide as a result by generating
this molecule that they called abet 1
upon treatment of cells they could very
selectively and rapidly degrade BRD 2 3
& 4 shown in this western blot from
their paper what they were able to
demonstrate was that really within one
to two hours they could completely
degrade BRD 2 3 & 4
what was particularly striking in the
study was not only could this work
across multiple different cell lines but
in fact led to improved biologic
activity compared to jq1 alone both in
vitro as well as in vivo subsequent sets
to this study the grey lab has also been
generating hair to hetero by functional
small molecules degraders to target very
different kinase --iz as well one
example of this came in Callison study
back in 2018 when the labs generated
this molecule known as Thal SNS o 32
when chemists in the group did was take
SNS o32 conjugated it to the little mite
in a similar fashion at the D bet one
small molecule that Dennis created as a
result when calyx treated cells you
cells she was able to demonstrate very
rapid and selective degradation of CV
canine is shown here again within one
hour of treatment you could almost
completely deplete CT canine
apparently our groups have had quite a
lot of success integrating a number of
different target proteins of interest
many other labs around the world have
also been able to use this strategy as
well for us we focused around
bromodomain containing proteins that are
highlighted on the left as well as
various different kinase --iz including
the cdks and most recently we've been
trying to degrade aggregated proteins
such as tau and proteases such as the
HCV protease so we think that this is
really a highly extensible intractable
strategy for depleting targets of
interest now when I joined the the teams
back in late 2015
after Jays lab had published that
initial D bet one study what we had
noticed over time was that this strategy
might have its limitations one of which
is that you need a high affinity ligand
to be able to bind your target protein
of interest as a result if you're
lacking that ligand you really can't
assess whether or not making a small
molecule 2 grader would actually have
robust activity towards your target
protein as a result we had a couple of
central questions that I'll try to
highlight throughout the presentation
with our development of our degradation
tag system what we wanted to do is take
a bit of a step back and try to develop
a universal tag based strategy that
would allow one to rapidly deplete a
target protein of interest this would
allow us to address on one hand whether
or not a target of interest was worth
going after and starting a medicinal
chemistry campaign to develop small
molecule inhibitors or degraders it
would allow one to evaluate whether or
not targeted protein degradation might
be an effective strategy for a
particular drug target and finally we
thought that this strategy might have
advantages over genetic approaches
whereby as I mentioned we could rapidly
deplete target proteins of interest
within one or two hours this could open
the door for really investigating rapid
biology particularly in the context of
signalling and transcription that I'll
that I'll highlight today
so this gave rise to our idea that we
could perhaps develop a tag based
strategy that we call our degradation
tag or our D tag system in this
particular system what we do is fuse a
target gene of interest to our tag that
I'll describe in a moment we then
develop header by functional
small-molecule degraders that bind that
universal tag in a very selective
fashion and then on the other end of the
molecule are hooked up to thalidomide
thus engaging sera blonde as a result
this can lead to the ubiquitination of
the fusion chimera leading to its proto
ZOA mediated degradation so what I
wanted to do today would sort of
highlight how we thought about
developing this particular system and
then how we've been leveraging it to
study oncogenic signaling which I
thought might be of interest to the
audience today how we've been leveraging
this to validate and also invalidate
different targets of interest and
evaluate rapid biology downstream of
transcriptional regulators and finally I
wanted to end on our efforts to try to
evaluate whether or not our system can
work not only in cells but in mouse
models what I hope that you can take
away from this webinar today is that our
degradation tag system is both rapid and
very selective
I'll give highlights on the MEC our
confirmations on the mechanism of action
of the system and how we've been
leveraging it to study fast biology both
in cells and and our ongoing work in
translating this in view what I also
wanted to highlight was that there are a
number of different tag base strategies
out there in the literature as well and
we initially turn to these and learned a
lot from the many papers in which not
only describe these technologies would
have used these technologies ones that I
wanted to just point out is being great
solutions that can be paired with our
approach as well include the auxin
inducible dagger on the halo tag system
the shield system in particular ligand
induced degradation and then the smash
systems as well so I highly encourage
you to take a peek at some of these
references that I highlighted here for
some of these comparable and compatible
strategies so in getting into the DTAC
system what we decided to do was
laughter one of the favorite proteins of
chemical biologists this is a protein
known as sk b b12
well Garrigan and Dennis had initially
shown in there d bet one paper was not
only could they degrade the bedroom
window payin proteins with D bet one but
they also fashioned a second small
molecule to greater which they called EF
k PB one by conjugating SLS to salute
amide what they were able to demonstrate
was that with treatment of cells with
the sk b p1 they could degrade
endogenous wild-type sk p b12 in a
sarabande dependent fashion
this was quite informative to us because
it gave rise to the notion that fkb b12
itself was highly degradable and we
could perhaps degrades as target protein
next in looking to the literature we
came across the shield system that Tom
Wanless and colleagues at Stanford had
developed
in 2006 they published a seminal study
which they demonstrated that a double
mutant version of fkp p12 could be used
as a tag
you
when hooking up this DD domain or
destabilizing domain to the target
protein of interest this leads to
destabilization of the target they then
described a small molecule ligand shield
one which upon treatment of cells leads
to the stabilization of this target this
is an inherently sort of the reverse of
the system that I'll be talking about
today but critically what it
demonstrated was that this skb b12 could
be effectively used as a tag what they
also demonstrated with others around the
world when they started distributing
their their technology was that in many
different contexts across many different
proteins fkb p12 and these double
destabilized mutant versions of it could
be used as a tag so this gave us a lot
of confidence that perhaps this could be
also a great place to start because @kb
b12 could be used as a particular tag
and finally back in 1998
Tim Claxton and colleagues at area
pharmaceuticals published a bump whole
strategy around skp p12 what they
described was a synthetic ligand ap 1867
that selectively combine to sk v PF 36
feet this is the particular mutant I'll
be focusing on today this F 36v creates
a compensatory cavity in fkb p12 as a
result a PA 267 can selectively bind to
this mutant version of FK b12 and not
wild-type we thought that this would
perhaps be a great starting point as we
started to develop hetero bi-functional
small-molecule degraders using AP 1867
and analogues that we generated of AP
1867 with our d tag system there are two
components the first of which is one
needs to tag their their target of
interest with mutant sk b p12 we've now
done this through the development of
lentiviral expression plasmids which are
gateway compatible allowing you to
rapidly clone in your target protein of
interest either with an n-terminal tag
or a c terminal tag we also commonly
include a second smaller tags such as
tandem h8 tags that are shown here which
helps in monitoring protein expression
if if you don't quite have a robust
enough antibody for your particular
target of interest we've also used
various different knockin approaches
such as crisp pitch and homology
directed repair that I'll highlight
towards the
the presentation to knock in our tag at
an endogenous locus the second component
of our system is the D tag molecule
itself what I wanted to do throughout
the presentation was highlight a little
bit about how we came about and landed
on D tag 13 as our particular molecule
that we thought was most universal here
what we did was make an analogue of ap
1867 that we call ortho ap 1867 that's
actually more selective than ap 1867
itself that was published by area
pharmaceuticals that binds mutant fkb
p12 and not wild-type we conjugated this
ligand to thalidomide to generate the
hetero bi-functional small molecule des
greater now a lot of the biochemical
characterization that we initially did
in terms of screening and identifying
this particular molecule is in the
reference that I've cited from my paper
that came out last year in 2018
sites that we gained in our initial
study and what we searched for our
outlines here on the right in terms of
the criteria that we were looking for
for a header by functional small
molecule d tag molecule what we first
wanted to do was find a molecule that
would selectively bind the mutant
version of skb p12 and not wild-type
we didn't want to degrade the wild-type
protein we wanted a molecule that could
dimerize fkb b12 and Sarah blonde we
also wanted one that would have no off
target activity in the entirety of the
proteome as I'll show here we wanted to
avoid activity on the Saira Bano
substrates that I mentioned such as it
gross an alias or iktf 1 and 3 as well
as wild-type FK b p we also wanted to
ensure that our molecule works through
the defined mechanism of action as I'll
show we wanted to ensure that the
molecule requires Sarah blonde as well
as a podium produce on machinery to
degrade a target of interest and finally
we wanted a small molecule that would
induce by the acute and prolonged
degradation of multiple different
targets across various different cell
lines that had the potential for working
in vivo so collectively these are the
some some of the criteria that we used
initially in a generation about of about
65 different molecules that we evaluated
and landed on d tagged 13 which will be
the focus of my discussion today now
skipping over some of the biochemical
data that I mentioned that you can think
you can find in my manuscript what we
set up initially was a dual luciferase
assay to identify small molecules that
actually penetrate the cells and could
lead to degradation selectively of an
fkb b12 F 36 beat music fusion protein
and so here what we did was hook up
wild-type fkb b12 and mutant fkb p12 to
nano luciferase as a result this would
allow us to use non-invasive
bioluminescence measurements to evaluate
whether or not we could degrade a
particular target of interest here
focusing just on FD b12 itself what we
were able to evaluate here
as selective degradation of want OFS KBB
12 versus mutant sk b b 12 what we found
here as exemplified with DTAC 13 that we
had really nice dose-dependent
degradation of mutant sk p b12 that was
fused to this nano luciferase and no
activity on wild-type fkb p12 at higher
doses we saw the character is to cook
effect in which you have saturation of
mutant sk b b12 as well as sarah blonde
as a result you fail to form the ternary
complex and can't degrade the fusion
building on this work then we could
confirm this by western blotting
demonstrating that 10 to 100 animal or
detect 13 treatment and cells that had
sarah blonde intact would lead to the
degradation of mutant sk b p12 we could
rescue these effects when we knocked out
Sarah blonde as shown here on the right
it's demonstrated to us that in fact
Sarah blonde was required for these
effects
now subsequently after identifying a
molecule that could actually penetrate
cells we decided to see if we could
actually degrade fusion proteins where
we fuse mutant fkb b12 to a particular
target of interest as I mentioned we
developed lentiviral plasmids where one
could fuse either with an n-terminal tag
or a c terminal tag here we started with
BR d for which we cloned into our system
and expressed in MV for 11 cells what we
were pleased to find was that upon
treatment of detect 13 within one hour
we could see effective degradation of be
ready for this lasted up to 24 hours and
also actually up to many days in this
experiment subsequently we were quite
excited so we started tagging a lot of
different target proteins of interest
that we were studying in the lab these
include mix ez h 2 h tech 1p l k1 and
mutant k r s these are either
cytoplasmic or nuclear proteins kinase
Azur transcriptional regulators or
signaling effectors what we found in
these n before 11 cells was in each case
we could nicely rapidly degrade each
target fusion protein here with evidence
of degradation within one hour of
treatment what we found was that mutant
KS was actually the slowest to the grade
where we saw degradation occurring
within four to eight hours after
treatment
now from here what I wanted to do was
was shift focus and highlight some of
our our work that we've done in further
characterizing mutant k-ras with our
system I think this example helps
illustrate how we demonstrated the
selectivity of our system and how we can
use it to study rapid biology downstream
of oncogenic Signori
so as a quick overview we and others
around the world have been interested in
trying to develop strategies to target
mutant k-ras the wrasse family are
signaling effectors that coordinate many
different signaling cascades including
the mek pi3 kinase royal GDS pathways
they're essential for promoting cell
proliferation upon mutation leading to
cell transformation the wrasse family is
the most highly mutated gene family and
in particular K rats as the driving
lesion and many different cancers
particularly in pancreatic cancer which
is one of our major focuses currently
the wrasse family is largely very
difficult to drug there's a lot of
really exciting new strategies
harnessing covalent inhibitors to target
KS g12c
however in pancreatic cancer G 12 D and
G 12 e are the most common mutations and
still effective strategies to target
this oncogene is necessary over decades
of work have focused around targeting
mutant k-ras directly as well as
indirectly and so today I wanted to
highlight using our D tag system how
degredation might be a useful strategy
for targeting mutant k-ras directly and
secondly what I wanted to highlight was
an alternative strategy that we and
others have been employing to identify
synthetic lethal interactors with
inhibitors that target map kinase
signaling and in what I wanted to do was
highlight a more recent study in which
we've identified a synthetic lethal
interact with mekin habitable to
validate with the D tag system so
starting with mutant k-ras what we
decided to do was internal e-tag mutant
KS and first demonstrate that our fusion
oncoprotein was functional we turned to
NIH 3 to 3 cells which are a mouse
fibroblast cell line that has been
commonly
used by many investigators over decades
of work to evaluate the functions and
activities of mutant que res what we
observed in line with the literature was
in fact that our fusion chimera was
functional this lead to at led to
elevated phosphorylation of mechs
as well as earth signaling as well as
phosphorylation of a KT shown in the
DMSO control Lane subsequently upon
treatment with our D tag 13 molecule
what we observed was that we could see
rapid degradation being triggered within
one hour of treatment we saw about 50%
degradation of rass by four to eight
hours we saw about 90 to 95% degradation
of rest in line with actually our MV
4:11 experiment the human leukemia line
what was particularly striking to us in
this experiment was actually looking at
the one hour time point in which
phosphorous was signaling actually
collapsed right back to baseline levels
within one hour of treatment here
phosphorylation of maca and
phosphorylation of a Katie looks
indistinguishable from the control cells
importantly treatment of our control
cells which were mocked transduce cells
leads to no effect on phosphorylation of
these signaling effectors as well we can
also do a number of different control
experiments to ensure that this was in
line with the the proposed mechanism of
action of our small molecule degraders
we could knock out Sarah blonde as I
showed earlier and rescue the effects we
could also block the proteasome with
parcels mm that's rescued the effective
degradation of mutant k-ras we could
block methylation which is required for
the activation of III ligases with ml n
for 924 and we could also saturate Sarah
blonde with lenalidomide we also
characterized extensively the biology of
these cells what we noticed just looking
at the cells was that when we put in our
functional mutant care assets led to
just characteristic changes in the
morphology of these cells compared to
control what was particularly striking
was that within 24 hours of treatment we
could flip the cells back to looking
exactly like the control cells we could
also quantify some of the changes in
proliferation and transformation and so
I'm just highlighting here one
experiment that we did where we
demonstrated that when we expressed
mutant krsna cells we had increased
cells in S phase upon degradation within
24 to 48 hours
the cells began cycling exactly like the
control cells
subsequently with the system this
allowed us to really hone in and
evaluate the selectivity of our de
grader and also evaluate whether or not
we were getting the expected effects
from degrading mutant ers
we turn to quantitative mass spec
proteomics in part to first evaluate
whether or not we had selective
degradation of Ewing key RS here we did
temporal profiling and I'm showing here
just the one-hour treatment we also did
a four hour treatment which is included
in my manuscript what we observed at
this initial time point was that mutant
K rats and the fusion chimera was
actually the only significantly degraded
target protein in the cell we didn't hit
skb b12 wild-type as we expected nor did
we degrade any other targets we also
coupled this with a phosphoprotein omics
experiment to confirm our Western blot
findings where we were evaluating
phosphorylation of mek eric and a katie
what we confirmed was at earth 1 and r2
where the most profoundly d
phosphorylated target proteins of
interest in addition we identified a
number of two other different signaling
molecules that we've been following up
on
and finally we couple this with
transcriptional profiling to look to see
how mRNA levels were changing into cell
upon k rest degredation in this
experiment i also compared this to
tremendous a MEK inhibitor what we
observe was within four hours and then
also at eight hours we could really
robustly flip the aberrant
transcriptional program that's
coordinated by mutant k-ras we also saw
these same effects when we treat it with
traumatic this gave us insight into the
fact that as expected the target genes
that were modulated upon k RS are
largely ones that were coordinated by
mek or signaling as well so overall
collectively these studies helped us not
only hone in and evaluate the
selectivity and the mechanism of action
of our d tag system but also allowed us
to start to demonstrate that perhaps
targeted degradation of this fusion
oncogenes and in particular g 12v itself
might actually be a very attractive
strategy for trying to target mutant k
RS now i wanted to switch gears a little
bit and talk about the second idea that
i mentioned in terms of identifying
potential synthetic lethal interactors
what's become quite quite clear with
small molecules such as tremendum and
not many other MEK inhibitors that are
currently used in the clinic is that
they fail to produce the expected
results in k RS meeting context as a
result we and others have been searching
for ways to sensitize cells in
particular and hopefully patients to mek
inhibition by degrading or inhibiting a
second target
so this study was done in collaboration
with Bill Hahn and Andrew a Geary's lab
here at Dana Farber Cancer Institute and
what the Hahn and a Giri labs had been
doing for quite some time our genome
scale CRISPR cast nine screens to
identify selective dependencies in
various different contexts in this
particular study what they set out to do
was treat cells and these archaea rats
mutant pancreatic or lung cancer cells
and I'm showing a snapshot from one of
the pancreatic cell lines that I'll be
highlighting in which they treated these
cells that are fairly resistant to MEK
inhibition and then perform the CRISPR
screen what they identified over and
over again we're not only components of
Mac kinase signaling that were synthetic
lethal interact or such as map kinase
one shipped to and other different
targets that were expected they also
identified in very very interesting
scaffolding protein in the shop too and
this came up is the most highly
recurrent synthetic lethal interact or
that would synthesize cells to
mechanization now a little bit a quick
background on shock to chop to binds
directly to M wrasse and complexes with
PP one see this complex actually
regulates syrian 2:59 phosphorylation
which is an inhibitory event on RAF
kinase upon syrian 259 phosphorylation
this actually abrogates the activity of
RAF itself so overall what the Hun and
aguirre labs had been able to Dennis
demonstrate after doing their CRISPR
screens or was to functionally validate
and evaluate shop 2 using genetic
approaches we then teamed up to tag shop
2 in these pancreatic cancer cells and
not that the endogenous locus creating
isogenic cell lines that would give us
tunable control over shot 2 this would
allow us to do chemical degradation
experiments to evaluate whether or not
shock to loss in combination with mekin
ambition actually was a potential
strategy that one could pursue further
here in the pancreatic cells a 15 animal
or dose of detect 13 what we could
confirm was a very nice degradation of
shock to evident within 30 minutes of
treatment and near maximal by one hour
of treatment in line with a lot of the
kinetics that we've been seeing with our
approach as a result this allowed us to
do combination experiments
you
what their lives have been able to
demonstrate and confirm from the
literature was in fact these cells are
quite resistant to mek inhibition so
here just containing comparing lanes one
two and three what's quite clear is that
upon tremendum treatment the cells
respond very quickly and there's a loss
in phosphorylation of herb however
within 24 hours of treatment
phosphorylation of Earth levels return
so here we were able to ask the question
now if shop two was in fact mediating
and was important in this recovery of
phosphorylation of Earth the degradation
of shock to lead to abrogation of this
effect and what we observed by degrading
shop two was really pronounced
maintained loss of phosphorylation of
Earth we could also confirm then in this
temporal profiling experiment that we
saw reactivation of phosphorylation of C
ref as I mentioned this is an inhibitory
phosphorylation mark as a result
explaining in part this effect on
phosphorylation of herb as a result this
was able to confirm some of the
interesting observations that they had
had in their genetic experiments that
those acute experiments could then be
extended to more prolonged proliferation
experiments so we could ask the question
of whether or not combining Meccan
efficient with shock to degradation
could in fact impaired proliferation
what we had been able to confirm was a
tremendous treatment upon shop 2
deletion leased a very pronounced effect
this could be rescued upon adding back
shock to wild-type or our fusion chimera
the shock to skb p12 fusion protein what
we had observed was in fact that shock
to itself is dispensable for
proliferation of these cells without any
perturbation we could confirm this not
only we shot to knock out with them with
D tag mediated degradation and finally
then we could do the real experiment
where we could then combine shock to
degradation which remained of treatment
and what we observe was that we could
have a pronounced effect on the
viability of these cells upon
degradation of shock to really
confirming this observation that shock
to loss in combination with
mechanization might be a potential
strategy that we should
in the context of using MEK inhibitors
and k res mutant context
now moving on a bit from some of these
signaling experiments that I wanted to
highlight today I wanted to give out
some references from some of our other
work that might help illustrate really
where I see some of the power of the d
tag system our first demonstration of
the utility of D tag is shown in this
publication here led by Michael Irv a
former graduate student in Jo Bradish
lab well we were able to demonstrate and
additionally initially identify it with
this component of the super elongation
complex known as en el was actually a
very important cell type-specific
dependency CRISPR wide June on my CRISPR
screens were able to identify en el as a
selective dependency because en el was
so important to these cells the only way
that could we could really study it was
by generating isogenic d tag lines here
we will we were able to tag en el using
our lentiviral system and knock out the
endogenous locus this again gave us nice
tunable control over en el and allowed
us to do a number of different
transcriptional and epigenomic profiling
studies to really define the mechanism
of action of en el this was a nice
example where we could go from CRISPR
screens to degradation based experiments
and also were important in our
validation of this particular target as
a as it as a dependency in AML in
concert with the study we were actually
also studying a kinase known as milk in
the lab which was thought to be very
important in triple negative breast
cancer cells hubert hong a former
graduate student in Nathaniel's lab have
been developing small molecule
inhibitors to target milk
however these inhibitors were having
really little to no activity when he was
treating them with these breast treating
these breast cancer cells we decided to
take a step back performed a number of
genetic experiments and also created
some d tag systems where we were able to
tag melt not not the endogenous locus
giving us again tunable control over
milk overall what we were able to
observe was in fact that milk seemed to
be actually dispensable for
proliferation of triple negative breast
cancer cells and so in this case our
study ended up being one where we sought
to invalidate milk as a kinase that was
important in this context
we've also been able to use knocking
approaches to knock in our tag and
endogenous flow side one of our first
examples here was we were able to knock
in our tag at the BRT for Lucas this
gave us an opportunity to selectively
degrade BR d4 with our d tag molecule
and compare this to our pan bet
bromodomain degraders D bet 1 and our
second generation D bet 6 which as I
mentioned hit B Rd 2 3 & 4 so this was a
nice example where we could then compare
the effects of selective degradation
vers pan degradation of this important
family we also teamed up with rick
young's lab and a study led by aim Abe
Weintraub in which we had been
investigating a transcription factor
known as Y y1 here again we were able to
use knockin approaches to tag Y y1 and
selectively degrade Y y1 this allowed us
to study how Y y1 regulates enhancer
promoter loop formation as well as
transcription in general and finally
more recently we teamed up with Margaret
kordell's lab at Baylor and were able to
tag a mutant oncoprotein known as NPM
one Lorenza brunette brunette e and
michel gondry two leaders of this study
together we were able to demonstrate
that we could effectively degrade npm
one by selectively tagging the mutant
version of npm one and then study its
effects on transcription and identify
the Hawks cluster as key essential
target genes downstream of npm one so
hopefully some of these references that
you can turn to in the future will help
illustrate how we've been leveraging the
D tag system to study transcriptional
regulation in part with e NL be ready
for YY 1 and M PM 1 and now I think it's
been valuable to us to not only validate
targets of interest but is an important
step for us to also invalidate targets
of interest and decide whether or not a
med medicinal chemistry campaign is
actually worth the investment of funds
and resources and the final piece of
data that I wanted to highlight today
was our ongoing effort in to see whether
or not we could develop a system that
had the potential to work in vivo and
what we decided to do here was generate
a fusion chimera that would allow us to
do non-evasive bioluminescence
measurements in vivo and what we did was
tag luciferase and express the
luciferase fkb b12 fusion in mb for 11
cells here is an abuse in vitro
experiment demonstrating that we could
effectively deplete luminescent signal
upon treatment with detect 13 we then
set up the following experiment we tail
they injected these M before 11 cells in
two-month mice and let them engraft and
and monitor their leukemic burden
subsequently on the first day of the
experiment we evaluated their baseline
luminescent signal the next three days
we performed treatments in the morning
after day two and day three we then
performed again
bioluminescence measurements this
allowed us to capture potential effects
on Lucifer a signal on the final day I
didn't perform the treatment in the
morning and we just did the lute
luminescence measurement to see how this
affected to see the recovery levels in
response to breakdown and wash out of
our compound in vivo so here's what the
data look like looked like from some of
our mice comparing three of our vehicle
for versus three of our D tag 13 treated
mice at baseline they had relatively
similar leukemic burden as exemplified
by their signal by day 3 which was where
we saw the most pronounced changes we
can compare the vehicle control to our d
tag 13 treated mice here we saw
significant repression of signal in upon
evaluation day 4 which was 28 hours
after our final treatment what we saw
was recovery of signal illustrating the
reversibility of our particular system
and here's the quantified data just
showing that the various different time
points where we saw really pronounced
effects both at day two and day three
these are four hours after treatments
where we did the non-invasive
measurements and then the recovery and
the reversibility of the system on the
final day and so this was quite an
exciting observation for us because it
was able to provide our first
demonstration that perhaps our system
had the ability to work in vivo and
degrade degrade targets in vivo and so
with that I'd like to start to wrap up
what I hope I was able to highlight
today was at the D tag system that we've
developed is able to induce potent
immediate and selective degradation both
in cell lines and in mouse models our
system enables both target validation
and invalidation with some of the
examples that I noted I think it's
particularly powerful for studying
transcriptional regulation these rapid
changes in in transcriptional signaling
that can occur upon loss of a
transcription factor or a
transcriptional regulator with some of
the studies that we've not published
that I that I tried to highlight I also
wanted to to note that I think this
system works quite well for looking at
and evaluating rapid changes in
signaling as hopefully I was able to
illustrate with our studies and our
ongoing work in evaluating mutant k-ras
and how targeted degradation of mutant
k-ras particularly the G 12v mutation
can collapse both oncogenic signaling as
well as transcription upon acute loss of
KS and this is able to lead to the
reversal of the aberrant biology of the
these mutant k-ras expressing cells and
finally some of our ongoing work in
terms of combining CRISPR screens and
evaluating synthetic lethal interactors
with various different inhibitors as an
example with the MEK inhibitor tremendum
and our identification of shock 2 as a
key scaffolding protein that might be a
modifier of sensitive sensitivity to
these to these inhibitors and so with
that
I wanted to thank a number of people
first and foremost I need to thank my
mentors Nathaniel gray and Jay Brandner
really for their continued mentorship
and support over the past several years
they've been really outstanding mentors
and I can't thank them enough I also
need to highlight two of my teammates
Dennis Buckley and Justin Roberts in our
initial description and demonstration
and development of the D tag system they
were really great friends and colleagues
to work with I also need to thank the
gray lab for being such an awesome team
to continue to work with hopefully I was
able to highlight our various
collaborators that I've been working
with over the years Rick and Abe Kwok on
and on Peggy in particular Lorenzo and
Michael bill Han Rida Jason as well as
Andy as well
all these collaborators have been
instrumental in terms of our
understanding and evaluation of the D
tag system and finally I wanted to
acknowledge my funding from the American
Cancer Society the bio program and the
Pinard fund as well as Nathaniel's
funding that has helped support the work
from the Hale Research Center as well as
the preneur Fund as well and finally of
what I wanted to note was that I really
tried to make our system as open as
accessible as possible for interest of
investigators to try to use we're happy
to share any reagents or insights or
ideas that might be helpful for various
investigators ongoing work we've tried
to set up a rapid express MTA that
allows us to share our molecules with
interested investigators our plasmids
and reagents are all on add gene where
you can find also protocols and some
guidelines and if you contact me I'm
also happy to direct you to some other
additional resources or send you them
myself as well and it's been great to
have the opportunity to really try to in
an open-source fashion try to distribute
to as many interested investigators as
possible around the world and so we're
really excited to see how the D tag
system performs and how this might
actually help push our understanding of
mental biology as well as application
towards treatments of various diseases
forward so again I wanted to end by
thanking the organizers for the
invitation for putting this all together
and I'm happy to also take any questions
as well thank you
and thank you dr. Novak for this
excellent presentation we've gotten lots
of questions coming in and let's get
started on these I want to remind those
remind our audience that if you do have
any questions you would like to ask
now's the time to do it just click on
that ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for so let's jump right in our
first question in vivo would you expect
side effects of inhibiting major
proteins
I think yes that's definitely true in
general I think that's a that's quite a
concern when you're trying to target an
endogenous protein either with a small
molecule inhibitor or with a small
molecule de greater for our tag-based
system the the great part about trying
to degrade a target is actually that our
molecule is so selective that the only
thing that we degrade is what's fused to
our tag so we can really get cell
type-specific degradation of that
particular target which really helps us
evaluate what the consequences of loss
of that target of interest is with a d
tag system however in general that's
definitely a broader concern when using
any kind of inhibitor or small molecule
de greater
thank you doctor neva our next question
how does D tag compared to other tag
based degradation strategies like halo
protec that's a great question so I
think our strategy is very comparable to
a lot of these different tag based
strategies it operates in a bit of a
different mechanism I think the most
comparable strategy indeed is the halo
pro tect approach developed by Craig
Cruz and colleagues at Yale one of the
key differences is that their strategy
works through a covalent mechanism so
the chloro alkane which binds to their
halo tag it's quite different that might
have some potential disadvantages when
you think about how degradation and
kinetics of degradation as well as the
reversibility of degradation might
operate in terms of comparisons to other
strategies I think one key advantage
here that were hijacking Sara blonde
rather than expressing a second
component being the e3 ligase machinery
such as the auxin inducible system and
that's kind of required for that system
to work and I think a key distinguishing
feature right now is that our strategy
as far as I'm aware is is the only one
that really has the potential for
working in vivo so but overall I think
they're all excellent strategies that
one can also combine with our strategy
as well perhaps to degrade two or more
targets of interest so it'll be
interesting to see how investigators
kind of also figure out ways to combine
our approach with with theirs as well
thank you our next question how
transferable are insights from d tag to
protract design
and I think that this is one where it's
to be seen we're trying to evaluate how
this might help us guide development of
pro-tax or hetero by functional
degraders with our particular system I
think on the on the one hand what's most
valuable is just for evaluating before
making the degrade er molecule whether
or not using D tag you can actually
effectively degrade the target protein
of interest and then elicit the expected
biology that you want to see so whether
or not you get the expected effects on
transcription and and signaling and
proliferation and so on so really as a
mechanism to validate that target I
think a limitation here and a concern
would be that it's still to be seen
whether or not this this approach can
actually predict whether a bi functional
molecule can can be made for that
particular target of interest in part
because we've seen examples where both
the tag and the target get you big wa
naite in response and so when you're
targeting the endogenous protein you
won't have the tag there to get the
ubiquitination on that tag so if that's
the driving event then you might have a
more limited scope of being able to
identify whether or not whether or not
this is very predictive of of a pro tach
itself but overall as a tool for target
validation and just evaluating
degradation I think it's a key platform
to be able to do that
dr. naved now have you seen any cases in
which there are differences and results
from genetic knockdown versus the tag
mediated degradation thanks for the
question I think overall would you see a
really high concordance as I as I showed
throughout the presentation between
genetic perturbations and then D tag
mediated degradation I think one of the
key advantages that we have is really
the kinetics of degradation that you get
so you can start to do your experiments
within one hour of treatment rather than
waiting many days after you try to do a
knockdown experiment or try to isolate
single cell clones in the CRISPR case
and so as a result I think it pairs very
well with genetic approaches it does
have a particular advantage after you've
built the system but overall we do see
really nice concordance between it
between the two we see striking
differences between trying to inhibit
targets of interest and then degrading
them and so I think that is where we are
beginning to see really profound
potential differences but overall what
these loss of function approaches it's a
great way of being able to do that more
rapidly thank you for that now we have
some great questions coming in we have
time for a few more I do want to remind
our audience that those questions we do
not have time for today and those that
come in during our on-demand period they
will be answered via the email address
that you provide at your time of
registration so let's continue on with a
couple more questions here Steph turn
Evette do you see a range of kinetics of
degradation with d tags
yes thanks for the question we we
definitely do see a range of kinetics I
think overall most targets of interest
when the system is working very robustly
you do see degradation as I showed
within 30 minutes to an hour there are
some cases like mutant k-ras where the
degradation takes a bit longer so you
can see evidence of degradation within
one hour of treatment however it takes
four to eight hours really to get kind
of that maximal 90 to 100% degradation
what's quite interesting is then really
once you're triggering the degradation
sometimes you're able to see in those
slower cases the beginnings of sort of
those immediate effects of losing that
target so it's in the example of rats
we only saw a 50% degradation within one
hour but complete reversal of the
aberrant aquagenic signalling program
within an hour of treatment but overall
I think in general between 30 minutes to
1 hour you do see you do see a nice
degradation of your target of interest
great thank you
your next question is it possible to
have different outcomes from the
inhibition of the same protein
yes I think this question is getting at
a key question kind of in the greater
field as to whether or not targeted
inhibition is can elicit different
outcomes compared to targeted
degradation and I think that that's
definitely true I think there are
examples in the field now that are
harnessing that this idea we're
depleting the target and getting rid of
all of its activities are actually quite
different from from killing the activity
of a particular target of interest such
as a kinase so kinase you might be able
to have a small molecule inhibitor that
affects its kinase activities however
the protein might have various different
domains that can bind to other effectors
it can function as a scaffolding protein
it might be localized in different
compartments in the cell and so just
inhibiting the kinase activity might not
be sufficient in eliciting the expected
response so we've seen cases then when
you can deplete that target of interest
using D tag or an endogenous degrade er
you can really have different and more
pronounced effects and so I think
overall those are the cases that we kind
of search for where we can see
advantages of degradation versus small
molecule inhibition
thank you next question when Surrey
blonde is hijacked by the D tag what
happens to the endogenous sub traits
substrate scuse me of free one
that question so that's something that
we were really concerned about and we
monitored very closely from the
beginning of our studies and so a lot of
that a lot of these kinds of control
experiments are are detailed in some of
our supplemental figures but overall
what we were what we try to ensure with
our d tag molecules is that we aren't
affecting any of the substrates of Sarah
blonde and so the proteomics experiments
are ones where we are able to really
assess that and try to evaluate whether
or not we're hitting any of those
targets so for example what we closely
monitor are always our a pros and a
leo's casein kinase saw for and some of
these other neo substrates that are
engaged by the image portion and we have
confirmed that our molecules
particularly molecules like detect 13 do
not hit any of those neo substrates I
think in general some of those Sarah
blonde neo substrates are still being
identified and we're continuing to kind
of monitor the field and evaluate them
but the proteomics experiments really
allows us to identify those in an
unbiased fashion and our molecules do
not hit any of those so really you get
selective degradation of only your
fusion chimera
thank you we have time for a few more
questions let's squeeze some in how
reversible is the D taxes
I'm great yet so definitely an advantage
that I kind of glossed over with all of
these degradation based approaches as
well as a detached system are that they
can be quite tunable and reversible and
so one can do washout experiments in
culture to be able to then temporally
evaluate recovery of the target of
interest and then see if you can reverse
the effects when when the target come
back comes back so we've done this and
it's in the supplement of our initial
key tag paper that came out last year
where we did these kinds of experiments
degrading mutant KS and then washing out
D tag 13 and looking at the kinetics of
recovery and then kinetics of recovery
of signaling as well so one can wash out
compound led target come back treat
again degrade target and so those are
some nice applications of being able to
use the system as well
excellent now this questions come in a
couple times does a system work in mouse
and human cells great yeah thanks for
the question so it does and so that's
why in part I tried to kind of highlight
some of that some of those notes in the
slides as well and I'm happy if there
are more questions too about specific
ones that we have also tested in
addition to the ones that I noted
throughout the presentation in terms of
Mouse cells those NIH 3 t 3s are mouse
cells we've done this in mouse embryonic
cells extensively as well so it works
great in those kinds of formats most
commonly we've done this in human cells
in part because we're studying human
human cancer and developing using human
cell line models and it really works
great in human lines as well so where
you're able to co-opt both mouse and
human Sara blondes with a D tag system
you
sorry about that can you degrade
membrane-bound target protein footsie
tag yeah great question so we are
actively working on that and it's
something that we can do so we have
mochas mostly focused around cytoplasmic
and nuclear factors just based on our
kind of research interests but overall
we can confirm that we've been able to
degrade membrane proteins and in
particular when mutant k-ras is active
in a Cell it does translocate to the
plasma membrane as well in order to
elicit its oncogenic effect so we do
know that we can degrade proteins in
various different compartments including
including the membrane as well
thank you doctor Nevada and let's wrap
with this final question what is the
spectrum of cell lines that have been
used for d tag studies
yeah great question so as I mentioned
we've done this in fibroblasts in human
and mouse embryonic stem cells as
examples and then a lot of different
cancer cell lines are what we focused on
so we've been able to achieve this and
in breast cancer cells and Leukemia and
Lymphoma models breast cancer cells and
many other both both solid and liquid
tumor models as well and so I think that
it seems to be quite tractable as you
move across systems in part because
Sarah blonde is pretty ubiquitously
expressed and so as long as you have
sufficient expression levels in your
context of interest it's worth starting
to to evaluate if you're interested in
that particular in nepeta in those
particular context
dr. naved thank you so much for this
excellent presentation in this great
interactive Q&A do you have any final
comments you'd like to leave our
audience
oh that's I appreciate that so I really
want to again thank the organizers for
putting this together
hopefully it was it was useful as I
mentioned on my last slide you can
contact it contact me through direct
message or tweet at me and I'm happy to
further share reagents insights
collaborate and and help you try out our
system for degrading your targets of
interests so thanks a lot for your time
thank you again and before we go I would
like to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions one final reminder those
questions we did not have time to get to
today and those that are submitted
during our on-demand period will be
addressed by dr. naved via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration I would I give one more
time thank dr. banana vet for his time
today and his important research I'd
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor cell signaling technology for
underwriting today's educational
webcasts this webcast can be viewed
on-demand and labret swil alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
we thanks for you for joining us and we
hope to see you again soon have a great
day
you